the mountains surrounding the town of
Bamm in Alberta Canada are a playground
for adventurers and luxury travelers
a Ferrari California T will fit right in
the 232 thousand dollar convertible is
aggressive to drive its 553 horsepower
v8 engine hits zero to 60 in 3.5 seconds
but it is also supremely comfortable it
even has a backseat and it makes you
feel ready for any adventure so the
great thing about the California tee is
that Ferrari made it as a Grand Tour
it's probably not the first car you
think of when you hear let's take a
drive in the Canadian Rockies but
actually it's perfectly suited to
driving on these long wide open roads
through the mountains
you should begin this day trip through
the Canadian Rockies with a pre sunrise
hike to the historic Lake Agnes tea
house start along the shores of Lake
Louise in Banff National Park with Magda
das a local hiking guide we are going to
Lake Agnes itself where the tea house
sits they do all of their own fresh
baking up there there's no electricity
so they have to make a big fire so Wow
oh that wait it's about seven kilometers
roundtrip but almost 400 meters of
elevation gain quiet beautiful place for
you this is all because of the glacial
melt from mount victoria behind us
we have here we have our a wild
strawberry green tea this used to be
just a refuge for hikers and it was
built by the CPR Canadian Pacific
Railway it started to serve G since 1905
she's been carrying on that tradition
ever since good spot the hike to the tea
house will take about two hours
round-trip and after all that walking
you'll be ready for some driving jump
back into the Ferrari and drive
Southwest through vamp and kootenay
national parks so everybody has said if
there's one thing to do on this trip
take the Bugaboo Lodge helicopter tour
it's so worth it so I can't wait to see
if it lives up hi Anna
we're gonna good welcome great to have
you here we are going over to the
Douglas in the Purcell mountains so
we're already ships ready let's do it
let's go soon this is where the sport of
heli-skiing got its start in North
America but a private helicopter flight
to the Bugaboo Lodge any time of year is
sure to delight
we'll just go out this way follow
bugaboo creek right up into the hundreds
what's really cool how is all the trees
are just changing color so pretty that's
probably the best time of year to be
flying in right now
at the lodge you can take a hike or ski
in the winter or you can just have a
light lunch on the lawn and enjoy the
spectacular scenery and pleasant company
of the lodge style this is beautiful
yeah this is I think one of the most
beautiful places in the world once
you've been safely reunited with the
Ferrari head toward radiant hot springs
and the southern entrance of Kootenai
National Park the Ferrari will have no
problem navigating the tight twist
through the cliffs of Sinclair Canyon
from here it's a scenic 18 mile drive to
Chateau Lake Louise hotel your final
destination
on the way you'll pass through the town
of field Canada
little rustic community has a population
of just 169 people and is in Yoho
National Park one of the great things
about this drive is the fact that there
little mountain towns along the way that
you can pull into and drive through look
at the little homes and they're really
fun to see they look like maybe in a
movie or something to kind of these
picture-perfect mountain towns
definitely worth driving from
you'll arrive at the hotel just in time
to watch the Sun slip behind Mount
Temple and mount wipe across the link
watch the sunset from the comfy confines
of the plush lobby lounge for the
terrace weather permitting hi thank you
so much
absolutely with the Ferrari safe with
the Hotel valet you can relax and have a
cocktail at the end of your exciting
Drive
you